الى الكويت حيث قدم رئيس مجلس الوزراء
الشيخ احمد النواف استقاله حكومته الى ولي
العهد الشيخ مشعل الاحمد وذلك اثر خلاف مع
مجلس الامه بشان الاتفاق على مطالب
الشعبيه يرغب النواب في دفع الحكومه
لاقرارها حيث جاءت الاستقاله بعد اصرار
الحكومه على موقفها بشان اعاده تقارير
اللجنه الماليه الى اللجان من دون تعهدات
اضافه الى طلبها سحب استجوابين مدرجين في
جلسه البرلمان اليوم الثلاثاء لوزير
الماليه وزير الدوله لشؤون مجلس الوزراء
[موسيقى]
الكويت ينضم الينا رئيس مركز الطاووس
للدراسات السياسيه محمد 2 سيد محمد حياك
الله معي في نشره الرابعه
استقاله جديده لحكومه فيها اقل من اربعه
اشهر هل
نعود كما هو المعتاد دائما في الكويت في
المشهد السياسي الى المربع الاول في هذه
الازمه
اول شيء مساكم الله بالخير انا اعتقد ان
شاء الله لن نعود الى المربع الاول لكن هي
استقاله وهذا يعني في شان السياسي دائما
دائما حكماء الديمقراطيه يكون دائما في
هناك خلافات بين البرلمان والحكومه اعتقد
ان هذه الازمه متفائلين بحلها بحكمه همم
بعض الحكماء من النواب مجلس الامه او من
الحكومه سوف نتجاوز هذه الازمه السياسيه
وان كانت المسببات يعني تحتاج الى حوار
اكبر من اجل حل هذه المسبباتها
نعم اعتقد ان هذه المسببات هو يعني اليوم
حكومه الشيخ احمد النواف هي حكومه اصلاحيه
وايضا يعني هذا الحكومه قدمت خطوات
اصلاحيه كبيره في المرحله الماضيه وايضا
الحكومه تتمتع بغطاء شعبي كبير خاصه بعد
الخطاب التاريخي الذي القاه سمو العهد
الشيخ مشعل احمد حفظه الله
هذه الازمه في العلاقه بين الحكومه
والبرلمان في الكويت هل تختلف في اسبابها
عن
سابقاتها ميادات الدوافع يعني نحن نعيد
نفس التجربه نفس المكونات بنفس الادوات
بنفس يعني الازمات ونتوقع انه تختلف
النتيجه
لا اعتقد ان هذه الازمه تختلف عن الازمات
السابقه اليوم الازمه يعني الحكومه بعد
الخطاب التاريخي الذي القى الشيخ مشعل
احمد حفظه الله خطاب حول يعني تصحيح
المسار السياسي في الكويت كانت الازمات
السابقه
تقريبا اخر ست سنوات الازمه بين المجلس
ورئاسه البرلمان اما اليوم في المجلس في
الصراع ما بين الحدود
نفس الازمه عدم الثقه فبالتالي نحن نكرر
نفس المشهد سيدنا محمد يعني انا لا اتحدث
انا انا اقول لك وجهه نظر الكثير من
الكويتين والمراقبين الذين يتحدثون عن انه
ما زالت الكويت تدور في نفس المشهد
السياسي ما حدث بالامس يتكرر اليوم لا
جديد في دون حل حقيقي لهذه الازمه من
جذوره
واعتقد استاذ خالد سبب الازمه لحل
الجذورها اعتقد ان السبب ان الذي جعل هذه
الازمه تكون موجوده اليوم هو غياب التنسيق
ما بين الحكومه والمجلس لذلك شفنا اليوم
غياب التنسيق غياب الحوار على الرغم من
الشيخ احمد النواف اليوم يملك كثير من
الادوات الاصلاحيه وايضا يتمتع بغطاء شعبي
لكن الشيخ احمد النواف ما كان في الفريق
الحكومي همم الوزراء القادرين على التنسيق
مع مجلس الامه او الوزراء الذي لديهم همم
يحققون اختراق داخل البرلمان هذا هو سبب
الازمه الرئيسيه لذلك شفنا بعض النواب صرح
بان سبب الازمه همم كون في الحكومات
السابقه كان في حوار اليوم كله سبل
الاصلاح موجوده لكن غاب الحوار بين
الحكومه والبرلمان وهذا الذي سبب الازمه
الرئيسيه
في الفتره همم المقبله في الكويت بعد
تقديم الحكومه والاستقالتها
اعتقد في ثلاث سيناريوات السيناريو الاول
قد ترفض استقاله الحكومه
ويجرى بعض التعديلات وترجع الحكومه كما يب
ولكن مع بعض التعديلات او تقبل الاستقاله
ويشكل الحكومه جديده في خلال يعني
الاسابيع القادمه او اننا قد يعني نشهد
انتخابات مبكره خلال فتره القادمه ان لم
تحلل ازمه السياسيه في الكويت يعني او
يوجد في هناك اختراقات لهذه الازمه اعتقد
ممكن نشهد همم انتخابات مبكره وايضا في
هناك الذي سبب الازمه عدم ارتياح النواب
من همم في خوف قد ايه في بالمحكمات تنظر
اليوم قضيه همم في همم المحكمه لمجلس
الامه قد يؤدي الى بطلع من مجلس الامه في
همم المحكمه الدستوريه لذلك جاء على
التصعيد لغه التصعيد همم تزيد في هذه
الفتره هذه السيناريات الاربعه قد تكون
اذا اخذ انظر وقتا اطول في معالجه نتحدث
على مستوى القوانين على مستوى احتياجات
الناس شارع التنميه برامج التطوير الصحي
التعليم يعني كيف يمكن النظر الى التداعيه
انا اعتقد
التداعيات المشهد السياسي اليوم الكويت
يعني صار لنا فتره طويله في المشهد
السياسي واحنا يعني همم
التنميه تراجعت في الكويت وهذا السبب
تراجع التنميه عدم الاستقرار السياسي
واعتقد ان نصل الى الاستقرار السياسي حتى
يكون هناك همم حوار صريح بين قوه المعارضه
والبرلمان باكمله
والحكومه اذا لم يكون هناك سوف تتاخر
التنميه كما تاخرت سابقا همم كل هذا يرجع
الى عدم الاستقرار وندور في حلقه مفرقه ما
لم يكون هناك حوار جدي وصريح بين كل اطراف
وايضا الحكومه بحاجه وفريق الحكومه بحاجه
للوزراء القادرين على همم التحدث مع كل
اطياف البرلمان وليس مع شريحه من شرائح
البرنامج